okay so before yesterday's Robert Muller
testimony I outlined for you that Donald
Trump went on a tweet storm melting down
completely with ten tweets in a period
of just a few hours
very very clearly panicked about what
was then the upcoming testimony of
Robert Muller my prediction was at the
time Trump is not going to listen to the
substance and even if he does he's not
really going to understand it because he
does have significant significantly
compromised comprehension abilities
Trump is going to go by tone Muller was
sort of slow Muller was sort of
forgetful Moeller appeared sort of
confused so Donald Trump was going to
come away thinking that he won just
Bigley because of yesterday's Robert
Moeller testimony that is exactly the
case Donald Trump does believe that he
won that he came out unscathed by
yesterday's Moeller testimony and we're
going to look at some of Donald Trump's
reactions now I'm not going to redo the
first segment from today's show I
already outlined for you the endless
ways in which Robert Muller's testimony
on the facts not on the tone confirmed
that Donald Trump is absolutely
impeachable at minimum more than enough
evidence to start an impeachment inquiry
but right now I want to focus on Donald
Trump's reaction now before I get into
some of the video it is actually sad and
horrifying that our president so
severely lacks comprehension skills to
understand the substance of what Robert
Muller confirmed yesterday which is that
Trump is impeachable Trump came out
thinking it was a great day for him
let's look at some clips starting with
Donald Trump's kind of big-picture
conclusion that Muller just had nothing
to say because Donald Trump did nothing
wrong
I think Robert Muller did a horrible job
both today and with respect to the
investigation but in all fairness to
Robert Muller he had nothing to work
with you know you can be a builder but
if they don't give you the right
materials you're not going to build a
very good building robert muller had no
material he had nothing to work with so
obviously he did very poorly today this
might be the most disconnected one could
be from the content of the hearing
Muller confirmed
ruction molar confirmed Trump directed
his lawyer to lie molar confirmed Trump
can be indicted after leaving the White
House Muller confirmed that
investigations are ongoing Muller
confirmed that as damaging as his report
was the scope was so limited that it
didn't even explore multiple areas of
wrongdoing by Donald Trump Muller
confirmed that Trump's actions meet all
three legal requirements to be
considered obstruction on multiple
counts Moeller confirmed that Trump was
untruthful in his written answers to
investigators now I could go on and on
but only someone who does not understand
what he saw or is lying could come away
with the conclusion that Donald Trump
purports to have come away with once
again here's another piece from earlier
and Donald Trump's little statement
where he again summarizes everything as
it was just lovely for me so we had a
very good day today the Republican Party
our country there was no defense of what
Robert Muller was trying to defend in
all fairness to robert muller whether
his performance was a bad one or a good
one i think everybody understands that i
think everybody understands what's going
on there was no defense to this
ridiculous hoax this witch hunt that's
been going on for a long time pretty
much from the time i came down on the
escalator with our first lady and it's a
disgrace what happened but i think that
a proved a lot to everybody in fact some
of my biggest opponents wrote things
today that i wouldn't have believed they
would have written and i appreciate that
they did that this might be the height
of confusion Trump claimed since day one
that the report exonerated him and
thanked Muller for it and went on
nationwide exoneration tour events on
the basis of Muller supposedly
exonerating him which Muller didn't do
in the hearing Muller confirmed I did
not exonerate Donald Trump now Donald
Trump has shifted completely and is
saying oh yeah
Moeller never had the right to exonerate
me well then why did you go on an
exoneration tour on the basis of what
you believed was an exoneration from
Robert Muller which it wasn't take a
look at this so there is no such a thing
he didn't have the right to exonerate at
you know it's very interesting people
mention exoneration that was something
where he totally folded because he never
had the right to exonerate and it was
covered very well by congressman Turner
and went to a conclusion we were if you
take a look at not only the report
beyond the report take a look at not
what he said but what he was forced to
say why did you use what you falsely
believed to be an exoneration from
Muller as evidence of your innocence if
your new position is Muller actually
didn't have the right to exonerate me at
all
so then attempting to bring Donald Trump
back to reality which is tough to do
some reporters actually started pressing
Trump a little bit on hold on a second
one example molar said you were
untruthful in your written answers and
Trump just buries his head in the sand
and says Nana boo boo
I wasn't untruthful you were untruthful
to the reporter and I wish I was kidding
when I said that this is effectively
what Donald Trump did but here is Donald
Trump telling the reporter that she's
the one who's lying can you imagine
anything more childish you can say
Mulder was too reserved you can say
Mulder was meek you can say Muller
appeared confused but Muller was very
direct and clear on the issues Trump did
not tell the truth in the written
answers we already discussed that in the
first segment so first and foremost this
is a president who is completely
disconnected from reality who thinks he
came off looking great after Robert
Muller confirmed impeachable wrongdoing
by Donald Trump during the hearing but
take a step back for a second does
anyone realize how dangerous it is to
have a president whose comprehension is
so compromised that this is what he took
away from the Moller hearings let's
assume for a second that Trump isn't
lying here and he genuinely thinks the
Moller hearings were just great for him
even though Muller confirmed impeachable
behavior by Donald Trump
what is Trump taking away from
intelligence briefings if this is how
much his how significantly his
comprehension is compromised
what is Trump gleaning from meetings
with foreign leaders if he can watch
what not robert muller said yesterday
and think that he got away unscathed his
comprehension is completely compromised
and he's the President of the United
States
aside from more immediate decisions
Democrats are going to have to make
about impeach or not in Pietra whatever
else this is a danger and I want to hear
from you about it I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show please follow both accounts
there